we're going to stop karate kicking the
crosswalk
button it's a good move this was on the
menu why were we ever doing
this these are these we eat with these
that disgusting wet Street metal these
are God's Forks why were we ever pushing
why were we ever pushing God's Forks
onto that wet
nickel it's always got a sheen on it cuz
you know 10 minutes earlier an unhoused
person was rubbing his foreskin all over
it just like I'm the mayor just like
getting a
getting a good coat getting a good coat
this is beautiful you're making a great
sound right now you're laughing but
you're also a little confused I like
that and I agree with you that's a
confusing
joke that joke needs to pick a
lane I'm sensitive enough to say
unhoused but I'm still like you know
they're putting their dick on stuff
right